de la Nouvelle Calédonie merci Monsieur
le Premier Ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Gérard Cherpion
oui
merci merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le Premier
ministre monsieur le Premier ministre
sous votre commandement qui confond
autorité et autoritarisme le bateau
France coule nous sommes face à un
gouvernement qui ne contrôle plus rien
avec des dissensions internes publiques
une majorité qui a implosé un paysage
syndical éclaté des manifestations
ultravolentes et population qui ne
comprend pas l'entêement de
l'exécutif plus de 90 % des amendements
sur la fameuse loi travail étaent issu
de la gauche et de votre propre majorité
ou ce qu'il en reste ce texte n'est plus
que l'ombre de lui-même à force de
renoncement et de rulade et Christian
Jacob ne vous en déplaisent la fort bien
montré vous avez engagé votre
responsabilité non sur un texte qui
renforce notre pays mais sur un symbole
car oui Monsieur le Premier Ministre la
loi travail n'est plus que le symbole de
votre échec
qui aura pour conséquence un nouveau
recul de la France en matière économique
et sociale vous vouliez donner plus de
place aux accords d'entreprise et vous
renforcez les branches vous vouliez
réformer le code du travail vous créez
une commission placée sous l'autorité
d'une autre commission en charge du
dialogue social une véritable usine à
gaz pire vous avez supprimé toutes les
avancées du Sénat en matière
d'apprentissage monsieur le Premier
ministre nous savions que vous n'aimiez
pas l'apprentissage vous l'avez prouvé
qui aimez-vous monsieur le Premier
ministre le Parlement partenaires
sociaux les entreprises les salariés les
jeunes cela saurait Monsieur le Premier
Ministre vous souhaitez prouver votre
force avec le 493 vous démontrez votre
faiblesse quand allez-vous enfin écouter
quelqu'un d'autre que vous-même quand
allez-vous entendre le peuple de
France la parole est à Madame myiam
elcomery ministre du Travail de l'Emploi
de la Formation Professionnelle et du
dialogue social merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député cher pion
quelle caricat
quelle caricature vous qui avez pourtant
travaillé de façon studieuse dans la
commission présidée par Catherine
Lemorton au côté de Christophe cirug et
vous savez très bien que tout ce que
vous avez indiqué là n'est pas la
réalité du texte vous le savez et c'est
vrai qu'il y a une forme quelque part si
nous voulons véritablement et c'est
notre souhait que notre pays avance je
pense qu'il faut cesser ces caricatures
où d'un côté la loi est vidée de son
contenu et de l'autre la loi justement
va beaucoup trop loin je vous assure
nous avons besoin de nous retrouver
autour de l'intérêt général et qu'est-ce
que l'intérêt général c'est justement de
faire que notre pays avance de trouver
de nouvelles formes de régulation
sociale et de nouvelles formes de
régulation sociale c'est d'assumer en
effet d'assumer en effet que c'est par
des accords entrepris s'agissant de ce
qui fait le quotidien des salariés que
nous pouvons améliorer les choses est-ce
que ça veut dire que il n'y a plus
d'accord de branche non le gouvernement
en effet aorté des amendements avec le
le rapporteur Christophe CUG la semaine
dernière parce qu'il y avait des
inquiétudes et justement ce n'est pas
des reculs c'est écouter écouter
unlassablement depuis février trouver un
compromis avec les organisations
syndicales réformistes écouter également
le pays apporter des précisions apporter
des clarifications et quel est votre
projet quel est votre projet ce projet
nous l'avons BRI côé en effet parce que
c'est la durée légale par accord
d'entreprise les 36 37 38 41 he par
accord d'entreprise payz 35 peut-être
c'est la fin de la garantie jeune c'est
les mini Jobs à l'allemande nous avons
deux projets de société complètement
différents l'aptitude à gouverner
monsieur le député Cherpion c'est à la
fois parler vrai et agir juste et moi je
remercie le Premier ministre d'avoir
pris ses responsabilités avec courage
avec